(cars roaring)
(people chatting and clanking dishes)
- You can do this.
It's not hard.
Tell her how you feel.
Give her the card and then leave.
Give her the card.
Tell her how you feel.
Leave.
Give her the card.
Tell her how you feel.
Move on.
- Hey man.
I believe in you.
- Uh...thanks.
Your support means so much.
- Oh yeah, listen,
confronting your feelings?
Difficult stuff.
You should be proud of yourself.
- Yeah
- Put her there.
(jazzy music)
(loud slap)
(playful music)
- Hey.
You're on time?
- Yeah, aren't I always?
- Not at all.
You were late to our graduation.
- I had trouble putting on my dress.
- I thought it was traffic.
- Bottom line is I'm here.
- Where's Eric?
- Uh, he's not coming.
- Oh, is he sick or something?
- No, I just thought it would be nice
if it was just the two of us.
(oppressive music)
- Oh, alright,
so I can't stay too long, so I...
- What?
We made reservations.
- I know, I'm sorry,
but I just have to get-
- Michael, what's going on with you?
- Nothing.
- It's never been this bad.
- What's never been this bad?
- It.
It.
- I just like things a certain way.
- Yeah, but it gets worse
when you're depressed.
- Fine.
I've been stressed a little.
- Depressed.
- Can you please just--
- Hello everybody!
Welcome to Cafe Blah's
open mic, LA's best comedy.
Who am I kidding.
None of this matters.
You don't care, I don't care.
Alright, let's do this.
First guy, Brian O'Barron.
Come on up here.
(people chatting)
- Yeah, I get it.
I'm a white male.
So what.
- Here.
Just open it.
(box crinkles)
- Michael, are you out of your mind?
- I'm sorry?
- I can't accept this.
This is too much.
- It's fine.
It's what you always wanted.
- Right, but I wanted
to get it for myself.
- Yeah, but we've been friends
for like eight years (mumbles)
- And then my mom told me
about how sick I make my dad.
I guess that's why I can't
smell lavender anymore.
- Is this an alpha print?
- Yeah.
- Jesus Christ.
- Think of it as a wedding gift.
- Okay, next up we have
Terrance Abbegetty.
(light applause)
(people chatting)
- Man, this morning I was (beep).
And there was (beep)
who was an (beep).
- I can't accept this.
- Mara, I need you to take this.
I went through too much
for you to just reject it.
- That was your decision.
You don't put this on me.
- It's always been on you.
It's always been you.
- Have you talked to Dr. Lyn recently?
- Did you hear what I just said?
- Yes, I heard you.
But as much as you want to unload
whatever you're going through on me,
I'm not going to let you.
- Just take the goddamn card.
(people fall silent)
- I believed in you, man.
- I'm gonna go.
Call Dr. Lyn.
I will check on you tomorrow.
- And if you just think about it,
even for just this one brief moment,
I get to be up here channeling, you know,
all of these dreams.
If someone has a 100 dollars,
I just need 100 bucks and that's it.
(brooding music)
(car engine rattles)
(loud, ominous music)
(chair scraping)
(phone ringing)
- Hello?
(bags thud)
(siren wails)